aldo symons rythme tous les détaillants
de vêtements subissent les contrecoups
de la fermeture de l'économie le paysage
de la mode du québec pourrait se
transformer totalement après la crise de
la coved 19 des visas kgb directrice
générale de la grappe métropolitaine de
la mode bonsoir débit zakaïb pensable
ces feignants quel est l'état de la
situation en ce moment après plusieurs
semaines de fermeture dans la mode en
général d'un chez les détaillants de
vêtements
on a en gros l'écosystème de la mode les
créateurs les détaillants les
manufacturiers les grossistes
l'événementiel aussi donc son dif est
touchée différemment les créateurs par
exemple se sont mis en mode solidaire on
en sait larges tag mode solitaire
ils ont fait une accélération de leur
virage numérique et ont pu faire du
commerce en ligne
les manufacturiers aussi se sont mis en
mode solidaire pour justement aider
notre réseau de santé nos québécois dans
la production de matériels de protection
a eu pour justement tout aidé le québec
donc leurs opérations ont été
complètement transformée en jour et nuit
sur le matériel de protection
et bien les détaillants part dans de
leur côté c'est très difficile parce que
les commerces sont fermés
l'école des centres commerciaux sont
fermés et il ya des frais qui continuent
à rentrer comme les loyers par exemple
est là mais thématique fait que ça fait
plus de sens et c'est plus c'est très
très difficile pour nos défaillances
moment combien risque de fermer leurs
portes
c'est une bonne question car notre boule
de cristal moi je prédis que dans les
prochaines semaines il y aura d'autres
commerçants détaillants qui se mettront
sur la protection des créanciers
c'est évident elle joue l'autre fille à
la presse suggéré à peu près un mois que
70% des détaillants se mettrait sur la
protection et de grosses structures et
leurs opérations pour pouvoir survivre
c'est très très difficile énormément de
mises à pied en ce moment et on espère
que les
commerce que ça rouvrir est ce que ça
dépend beaucoup des centres commerciaux
ça dépend beaucoup des centres
commerciaux bien évidemment parce que le
commerce électronique c'est important de
grands détaillants avaient déjà fait le
virage
par contre ça compense pas pour les
ventes physiques
il ya aussi les frais importants que les
détaillants doivent assumer
mensuellement
on parle par exemple la vie en rose des
5 millions pour les loyers dont 60
millions par année qui doit payer un
loyer
sans oublier que l'industrie de la mode
est affecté par des inventaires donc
c'est un mode cycliques donc des pertes
d'exploitation des pertes de ventes
le l'automne le printemps était perdue
l'été du festival difficile nous faut
préparer l'automne pour être plus fort
donc oui des frais des fraises des
magasins qui sont fermés les centres
commerciaux et de façon importante ou à
montréal parce que le soutien
gouvernemental est suffisant en ce
moment où ciblée est ce qu'il correspond
bien à votre industrie
c'est une très bonne question c'est un
peu seul enjeu c'est qu'un autre des
grands détaillants ont pas accès à
beaucoup des mesures qui ont été mises
en place les gouvernements ont réagi
très vite et ont beaucoup aidé les
travailleurs donc c'est très bien pour
créer de pouvoir d'achat
maintenant les grands détaillants aux
pas eu accès par exemple à l'aide à
lampes led salariale parce que les
employés ne sont à la maison et de
travail façon dont étaient mises à pied
dans les commerces aussi et on passait
non plus à l'aide aux baux commerciaux
au loyer parce que c'est pour les
petites entreprises dont qui ont pas
accès à ça pour les prêts d'urgence du
fédéral du provincial c'est très
difficile parce que les banques malgré
le fait que ces garanties par
investissement québec et nos
institutions
les banques sont créatives donc au lieu
de créer de la nuque de nouvel argent de
la nouvelle dette
ils font plutôt protéger les deux
existences donc c'est très difficile à
quoi va ressembler des bises au crible
la mode au québec
après cette crise comment on peut se
projeter dans le futur
des belles chansons donc on est vraiment
très fort au québec on a vraiment un apn
de même facture de détaillants tous les
grands détaillants nationaux au canada
leurs sièges sociaux sans montréal donc
on est vraiment à vous donner c'est une
innovation
donc je suis sûr qu'on va travailler
ensemble tous ensemble avec les
gouvernements avec les bailleurs pour
pouvoir trouver des solutions qui sont
constructives et qui va respectives ont
vraiment un constructeur pour toute
l'industrie puis aussi si les commerces
peuvent ouvrir une accélération du
commerce en ligne ce qui est
extraordinaire on a on avait quand même
un petit retard à ce niveau là donc ça
m'a permis d'être plus d'une avant
d'investir à ce niveau là donc je prédis
que des aides qui viennent rapidement je
parle de jours
je pense que l'on peut aider nos grands
grands détaillants compense où la vie en
rose bikini village ardennes dynamite
garage le short aux frères guénot qui
sont tous à montréal
s'amuse à québec on a une taille pour
les pleurs faire passer des quelques
proches et moi pendant la firme doute
les premiers mois d'ouverture pense
qu'on va avoir une super industries de
la mode avec beaucoup de créativité que
l'écosystème c'est ce qu'on souhaite et
qu'on vous souhaite merci beaucoup à la
prochaine
oh